Glenn Greenwald has seen stories like
this very very up close and personal
he's the host of system update on Rumble
he broke of course the most famous
leaking story in American history the
story of Ed Snowden he joins us tonight
Glenn thanks so much for coming on I
should say and I don't be quiet and let
you speak since you know this better
than anyone but we left out a lot of
details that are being reported in the
Washington Post New York Times Etc
tonight about the leaker and where this
all came from because honestly I don't
believe anything and it's very hard to
know what's true we're all being spun
we're all being lied to and we just
didn't want to repeat the lies so with
that what do you make of this
I can't think of a incident Tucker that
reveals more vividly the real function
of our nation's largest media
corporations than what just happened
here if you're a real journalist
somebody who's devoted to transparency
bringing shining a light on the most
powerful government actors when they
align the American people and informing
the public you would be celebrating this
person who stepped forward and risked
his security to show his fellow citizens
that the government was lying about this
incredibly important war with a nuclear
armed power that we have actual troops
deployed on the ground in Ukraine
there's going to be no diplomatic
resolution through at least 2023 that
zielinski is planning on using our
weapons to strike deep into Russia which
we were told would never happen risking
escalation he did the job of what
journalists claimed to do which is
showed the public the truth if you work
for the intelligence agencies you would
be furious at this person you would hate
him because he revealed that you just
lied he exposed the true truth about
what you were doing what's amazing is
the New York Times The Washington Post
all the people who were at that Pentagon
briefing today think the way the CIA and
the Pentagon thing they hate this person
it was the New York Times The Washington
Post that did the FBI's work and found
the leaker and led the FBI to him
they're demanding that he be punished
they're demanding that the government
clamped down and keep things more and
more secret what kind of journalists
would ever do that would want to seal
deak or exposed and punished and then
demand that the government keep even
more secrets but that is what this these
these media corporations are there to do
they love leaks when the CIA and
Homeland Security tell them to leak
that's when they disseminate propaganda
in the public like they did during the
Trump years when they leaked the
transcript between Michael Flynn and
Ambassador Kinsley act the most serious
kind of leaking crime the Washington
posted that nobody looked for that
leaker nobody cared everybody cheered
because it served the interests of the
security state but when it comes to
trans currency that undermines the
agenda of these agencies and that proves
to the American people what the truth is
it's amazing that these journalists are
on the side of the government and will
actually hunt down the leaker and demand
that he be punished even more
I just don't understand
how any journalist could collaborate in
hiding the fact that we're in a direct
hot war with Russia maybe you support
that maybe you don't but how could you
hide something that's significant the
most significant fact of Our Generation
from the public how could you do that
it the only answer is that you don't
actually have a journalistic mindset
that you far more identify with your
with your job is working for the
government than working for the American
people if you look at the history of the
most important journalism stories it's
exactly insiders like danielleberg sees
that the government is lying to the
American people about the war in Vietnam
saying we're winning when in reality
privately they're saying we're losing
and he goes and he shows the the
American people the truth or Edward
Snowden or her James Clapper falsely
deny the NSA was spying on American
people he had the evidence in his hand
and he risked his security to show the
truth same things Wikileaks did this is
what you celebrate in journalism art
journalists meaning the media
corporations hate this because they
actually work for their government that
is their true Allegiance
you have to defend truth tellers you
cannot abet lying if you have an entire
country based on lies it just does not
end well you have to tell the truth I
think you're certainly a living example
that Glenn Greenwell thank you very much
thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight